And this is what the media does with
absolutely everything. They want you to
believe certain things so that you'll
continue to waste your life energy even
though they hate you. You have done the
same exact thing. I don't understand
you, bro. What are you doing? What games
are you playing? And I want to know what
games are you playing,
man? Just imagine the people back in the
day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years. What is one thing that they would
carry with them? The Quran. Why? because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets. Brothers and
sisters, imagine you have a app, the
Qurani app, which not only shows you how
much rewards you get, but reminds you to
read the Quran, gives you reminders.
Download the Quran app now and let it
testify for you on
your read wherever
you brothers and sisters and dear
friends. I don't know what to make of
Andrew. Before he came to Andrew, he had
some weird belief systems about Islam
and thinking that it's only the
adulterous woman that gets capital
punishment. So, we done a video trying
to advise him slash refuting him and a
red pill kind of stuff. Then he became a
Muslim. We assume the best in him,
defended his honor, um that he's
changed. He's a new man. He's a rever
him some time to improve. And then this
Ramadan, the gambling, the drinking and
eating and all that kind of stuff. And
then before that in three separate
instances of attacks that have been done
which were you know terrorism but um he
blamed Muslims and Islam when he had
nothing to do with them. So I don't
trust him. But in this interview that he
had with Tracy this woman she's I think
Lebanese. I don't know for that matter.
I don't know if she's a Muslim or not a
Muslim. I have no idea for this matter.
But let's watch and see where is Andrew
now because going back to Dubai Tam Khan
again. Uh maybe Tam Khan has put some
sense into him and maybe he's repented.
I don't know. But let's I don't know
what to make out of him. Let's just
watch for oursel in. And you guys tell
me what you think. I can't tell you how
many young boys messages I read only
saying, "You have got me out of my
I'm so lucky to be part of this
university. Um, I just was able to make
so and so amount of money." I've read
multiple multiple multiple little guys.
I don't know how old they are, all
saying amazing things like they are
really really doing really well for
themselves because of that. So, it's
it's really nice to see that you have
that impact. It is, but it's kind of sad
that we live in an empire of lies where
the people they say are the good guys
are the bad guys and the people they say
are the bad guys are the good guys. You
think about it. Let's actually analyze
this. I'm inspiring men to not be
depressed, to believe in themselves, to
go to the gym, to stick up for what they
believe in, to say what they think, and
then I'm offering them a platform that
allows them to make money and dedicate
themselves and be constantly motivated
to be in fantastic physical condition
and make money and be financially free.
I should be a hero. Why am I treated so
badly? Okay, I mean, he made some very
valid points. He's telling people to do
good. He's telling young men to do good,
etc. Uh, but why is he being treated so
badly? Why is he not deemed a hero?
Don't forget those words cuz we're going
to come to those words. Very important.
And by the way, I would not encourage
anyone to sign up to his university.
However, does he encourage men to be
more men, more masculine? 100%. In a
society where we're living in where men
have become absolute feminine and
divorce rates are rocketing because men
are not leading women and women are
leading theirel and they've become more
masculine, Andrew Tate is needed. Let's
get this to it. And he is to a certain
extent. There is certain the stuff that
crosses their career yet. But Andrew
Tate has done many benefits, not total
benefits, but many benefits for the man
for the man to better himself and be
masculine and as a leader. Definitely
100%. But that's not our problem here.
Let's carry on. You're not smart enough
to do the research and work it all out
and do the details. Here's a simple
formula. Whoever they say is good is bad
and whoever they say is bad is good.
That's literally waking up now. I mean,
especially with what what has happened
uh with Israel and Palestine with how
much the media twists the truth and how
much it enraged so many people. If that
is not a lesson for you to say maybe not
everything the media says is right, why
is that applicable when it suits you and
your narrative and something you want to
defend but it can't suit something that
you know maybe it's not part of your
circle, maybe it's not part of what
you're trying to defend, but I think
Okay, good. So again, Andrew Tate has
made some very important points and I'm
going to replace Andrew Tate's name with
Islam very soon and it's going to make
sense to you in guys. So what did he
say? He said just it say if you haven't
got the time to do the knowledge study
etc. It's very simple. Whoever they deem
to be bad is good and whoever they they
deem to be good is bad. No problem. I
accept that. Let's carry on. Inshallah.
Let's carry on and entertain speaking
some deep facts and and and the media.
Another trick they do and this is
something else you have to be very very
careful. A lot of people don't do this
often enough. It's not only what they
say, it's how they say it. And this is
so important and we can talk about
Israel Gaza quickly because you
mentioned it. It's a perfect example.
When Hamas and the Palestinians defend
themselves, it's a brutal massacre. When
Israel murders innocent civilians, it's
a tactical strike. those differences in
languages. Brutal massacre, tactical
strike. Now, we both we know that a
tactical strike is a collapsed building
on top of children. We know that there
is missing limbs and dead women,
children, and men. We know how brutal it
is because we can now see the video. If
X wasn't a free platform, we wouldn't
even see the videos. So, if you just
read tactical strike, you imagine, ah,
they picked the one bad guy out of the
group and it was tactical and they
sniped him. But it's not that, is it?
It's collapsing buildings on top of
innocent civilians. But when Hamas
defend themselves, even if they're
killing other soldiers, which is the
basic prerequisite of war, it's a brutal
massacre. So when you're listening to
what the media say, it's not only what
they're saying, because sometimes
they're unfortunately forced to tell
some version of the truth. Then what
they do is they say it in a particular
way and they lie by omission. And by
omitting certain parts of the story,
they can tell the truth while also
lying. This is very, very common. They
do this a lot. In fact, they usually do
it when they attack a man's reputation.
Okay, let's just stick with that before
comes and talks about himself being that
man who's being attacked by the media
which um I'm sure that's a reality. Uh
he said some very valid points there.
Very very valid points. So the media use
specific words like killed. Yes. Killed
and died. Yes. When it comes to for
example uh Israeli citizens who died,
most of them are IDF soldiers. They've
been killed when thousands when
Palestinian children, men, women and
children have been massacred. It's they
have died. One's dying. Dying just means
you just everyone dies. We all going to
die. But the other ones are being
killed. So you can see that they play
with and it's the same with when it
comes to strip clubs. They don't call
them strip club because it sounds very
tacky. They call it gentleman's club.
Yes, they play with words. And that's
why the prophetam said speech is like
seah. So he knows very well this. The
question I want to ask Andrew Tate very
simply is then why did you do the same
with blaming three attacks about
Muslims? Why did you do that? Cuz you're
talking about the media. You're talking
about stuff like look you're saying
stuff like you know what you just said
now and then you're saying about uh why
am I being treated so badly? You know uh
why uh whenever they tell you something
is bad rather it is good and if it's
good it's rather bad. You say all of
this stuff and it's so true what you're
saying. I could not agree agree with you
more but you are the same man in social
media on Patrick Peter David's show etc.
millions of people watching you where
you spew this nonsense etc that innocent
Muslims were attacking a a a a whole um
riot started why did you do what you
blame the media I do not understand for
the love of me for please for the love
of God why did you do and use the same
tactics against Islam and Muslims I'm so
curious you're blaming the media and
that's why I want to change the word and
take to Islam the way you are saying
that you know this is what they do
against you and d and this this and go
and blah blah blah, but replace that
with Islam. Why don't they deem Islam to
be a hero? Is that obviously it's not an
individual, but Islam to be a a a
religion that's saving people? Because
Islam is doing that. Islam is there to
tell the people don't gamble. Don't have
sex outside of marriage. Don't drink.
Don't do drugs. Yes. Don't gamble. Don't
do this, this, and this. Yes. Why? Why
is the good bad? Like for example, the
same thing applies to Islam and Muslims.
They deem them to be bad than rather
good. Yes. But then why did you join the
bandwagon and make Muslims Muslims
specifically the bad guys? So that means
to your standards when you deem the
Muslims to be bad that they were
actually rather good. No, because if you
you you've done the same nonsense, the
same lies like the media does. Why did
you do that? Because now it's backfired
on me. Look, I've caught you out. I've
caught you out here. So I can talk about
this in personal experience. What
they'll do if they want to attack a
man's reputation is they would call
10,000 women who know him and 999 would
say he's a great guy and then they'd
find the one who says he's bad and
they'd only mention her. They don't
mention the 999 who say he's good. Even
if those 999 say the other one's a liar.
They don't mention them. They omit it.
They only show that one and they say,
"Oh, we're telling the truth. This is
what she thinks. This is what she says."
But they cut off so much of the story
that they're not telling the truth.
Okay. Again, this applies to Islam.
Again, look, you're talking about
yourself, Andrew. We can clearly see
you're talking about yourself. But
again, this applies to Islam. Yes,
Islam, Muslims do, you know, so many
good. So many good. But they will get
that one thing that they Muslims may
have done bad or whatever or somebody
came and talked the rel certain verse
out of context etc. or done atro
atrocious act of violence or whatever.
But you before they even do that and
say, you blame Muslims. They don't even
the perpetrators in this case. If there
was Irish, you can say, you know what,
okay, you know, we can blame you for
generalizing them all, which is the way
you've been generalized with all those
999 women and one good
whatever. Why did you do the same? Why
did you do the same? You're criticizing
the uh the media. Yes, you're
criticizing them, but you're doing and
behaving just like them. Please tell me,
Andrew, I'm so so like intrigued to find
out why you're doing this. And this is
what the media does with absolutely
everything because the primary objective
of the media is not to inform you. Think
about this if you're watching this at
home. Think about this. Why do the
people in charge of the world want you
to know anything? Who are you? Get over
yourself for a second. They don't give a
if you live or die. You could die in a
car crash right now. You think they give
a about you? They don't want you to know
anything. They want you to believe
things and they want you to believe the
things that suit their agenda. They
don't want to educate you ever. They
want to propagandize you. It's kind of
amazing how arrogant people are when
they go, "Oh, well, I I I read this. I
saw this. I'm informed." No one's trying
to inform you, friend. You're not
important enough. You don't get
presidential briefings. Nobody gives a
about you. You're another nobody
cockroach in traffic. So, no one wants
to inform you about anything because you
have no power or capability. Nobody
cares about you. They want you to
believe certain things so that you'll
continue to waste your life energy. They
want you to believe certain things so
you'll continue paying government taxes
even though they hate you. Okay, one
second. And here, I can ask you the same
question again. I can ask you the same
question again. Why did you spew those
lies and those nonsense? Yes, they want
you to believe a certain thing. You did
exactly what mainstream media was doing.
Believe the Muslims are your enemies.
They don't want good for you. They are
there to hunt you and kill you and ma
you.
And why did you do the same thing? I
want to know. You are criticizing the
media, mainstream media, and you did
exactly the same thing by vilifying
Muslims as a Muslim yourself. Okay. And
by the way, sorry, like you are you're a
Muslim. Yes. You have done the same
exact thing. I don't understand you,
bro. What are you doing? What games are
you playing? I want to know what games
are you playing, man. You're criticizing
the the mainstream media, but you're
doing exactly the same thing as them.
They wanted you to continue sitting at
home miserable and depressed believing
your life is worth living long enough
for you to build the roads and build the
bridges and then end up jumping off of
one of them. That's all they want to do.
So, it's kind of amazing and not
complain where your tax dollars are
going. Absolutely. This is the thing.
So, it's kind of amazing that people who
watch the mainstream news or interact
with it at all are arrogant enough to
believe that the BBC are building this
whole big studio and hiring these
professional presenters and getting
these very nice cameras and putting
together these video presentations
because they really want to inform this
nobody about how the world works. Like,
get the over yourself. Yeah. Get get
over yourself people. No one. They don't
care about you knowing anything. If it
was up to them, if they could click and
make you believe what you need to
believe, there would be no news. There'd
be no news at all. In countries where
the people are already doing what the
government wants them to do, there is no
news. They just get rid of the news.
Well, we don't need the news. We need to
tell anyone about the news. No one needs
to know what's going on in the world
because they're already doing what we
want. Right. And the less people are
doing what they want, the more news
there needs to be. Work it out. Well, I
am trying to work out, Andrew T. And the
question I'm asking is if you despise
the mainstream media so much, and you
are absolutely correct. I'm not I'm not
denying everything you're saying. It's
absolutely spot
on. But why did you do the same thing as
them? Why did you vilify Muslims and
Muslims had nothing to do with these
three attacks? Why did you do that? The
very strate strategies strategies they
use. Yes. Yes. The manipulation they
use, the deception they use. You did the
same thing with Muslims. Why? Please
answer me. Why? I want to know why. So
you were on Piers Morgan on October 9th
if I'm not mistaken. And before then, I
mean, that's when you really spoke out
about Israel Palestine. And before then,
yeah, you had a lot of conservatives on
your side only because that you kind of
spoke the same language. You had the
same ideologies. I know that you don't
identify as a conservative per se, but
they shared a lot of your point of view.
So, no one really attacked you. No one
really cared about the things and the
out like things that you were saying.
But all of a sudden, October 9 came, you
talked about Israel, Palestine, you
defended um Palestine, and then all of a
sudden you had your issue in Florida
where everybody attacked you, everybody
came after you. Tell me a little about
about the selective outrage and the
double standards. Yeah, there's a
interesting conspiracy theory that
there's a particular group of people who
control the world and they control the
media and they control the money and
they control the banking and if you
speak against their interests, you pay
the price. It's an interesting heard
that. Yeah. Very strange. What? First
time. Yeah. They were actually on my
side and then as you said, I on October
9th, which was very soon after October
7th, called what Israel was doing a
disgusting genocide. And I said it
before anyone else did. And I said it
against my legal council's advice. And I
said it because I thought it was the
right thing to say. And at that time,
nobody else had really understood
quickly enough that the beheaded baby
beast story was a lie and that Israel
were being disproportionate in their
response. And as soon as I did that, all
of these other influencers on the
conservative side, plus a whole bunch of
bots, all of this started to just whip
up a storm trying to damage my
reputation and damage my name. And
primarily, they were just saying that I
was, you know, the usual things,
anti-semitic and I was a bad person. And
then they tried to attack me because of
my history of owning a webcam studio.
And they said that I'm bad. I obviously
made it clear that Only Fans donate
millions of dollars a year to Apac,
which Apac of course are the Israel
lobby, which are heavily involved in
American politics, and Only Fans, who's
owned by a Jewish man, uh, donates
millions of dollars to this day, but
they don't care about that. They care
about supposedly something I did 15, 16
years ago for some reason. Anyway, very
strange coincidence all of this. Um, but
the Overton window has shifted now, I
believe, and I think everybody
understands what's going on. And uh
there's been some recent developments
also between the relationship of America
and Israel in the last three to four
days which are very interesting. So
we're going to have to see how things
play out. But so guys, you can see
clearly how he talked about the
mainstream media and the people at the
Torah and he knows exactly what he's
talking about. These Zionists who
control the world yet the Zionist. Yes.
Not Jews Zionist. Yes. Not every Zionist
is a Jew, but not every Jew is a
Zionist. Let's make that very
categorically clear, guys. So yes, they
turned against him. They turned against
you. Yes. And they knew exactly that.
when you talk about the truth about the
Palestinian cause and whatever it is for
that matter, you were attacked against.
Yes. So you can see clearly that the
Muslims are their public enemy number
one because we are the ones that are
trying to get people to follow the one
true path of God and stay away from all
degeneracy. The western world attacks
Islam but Islam is the only source the
only um fight last fight left against
degeneracy and evil is Islam. So they
attack it but you join that team. You
join that team and blame Muslims. Yes.
And again, like you said, Only Fans is
owned by And you made a very, very good
point. Only Fans, they donate to Apac.
Yes. However, they came and blamed you
for whatever reason about the webcam
thing that you did back in there, back
in the days, etc., you know, and they
tried to uh pin that on you and try to
um you know, get you arrested or
whatever for that matter. But again, the
very someone on an industrial level only
fans, yes, is something similar to what
you did in your past. But they can
casually just, you know, um, take
advantage of these, uh, girls, young
girls, young kids who are being groomed
in those places. It's pornography. It's
destroying society at large and they
make millions and they donate and nobody
says, "Oh, but an eye." It's true. Get
people emotionally riled up over
subjects they don't even understand or
know. This happened recently with the
hooties. It was funny before Trump
started bing the hooties. I noticed the
news was talking about the hooties all
the time. We have to get the hoodies.
The hoodies, the hoodies, and everyone
walk around. Yeah, we get the hoodies.
I'm like, "You didn't even know who the
hooties were 3 days ago. It is." But
they could just make you dislike these
people. So they can murder them on mass.
How do they do that? Cuz they can
emotionally affect you. I can't be
emotionally affected. In the West, if
they have an idea that they want to sigh
off the population with, they aim for
children and women first. They don't aim
for the men. We're hard to convince.
That's what they did with the October 7.
The first thing that came out was
behavior. Of course, a lie to trigger
women. I got in an argument with
somebody when the Taliban retook
Afghanistan. And the Taliban I was on
Pierce Morgan and he sat me down and he
said, "What do you think about the
Taliban preventing women from going to
school?" And I said, "Well, I don't live
in Afghanistan. I'm not Afghanistani. I
think the Taliban have a very difficult
job to try and be the government of a
war torn country like Afghanistan. I'm
sure that their decisions are not always
perfect, but it's their government and
they're a sovereign nation and we
believe in sovereign nations, don't we?
So, they made their own decision. And he
said, "Don't you think that's
disgusting? Don't you think that should
be allowed to go school? We should do
something about it." And I sat and said,
"Why don't the women do something about
it? Why do men have to go die?" I mean,
Ram says, "Uh, that's it. I'm not going
to say much in. But as you can see, uh,
you know, like, you know, he was being
asked rightly said, so yeah, okay. Um,
they make the Houthies look bad, they
make this people look bad, they make
that anyone, they they decide who is bad
or good. It's as simple as that. They
make they decide who is bad and good.
And not only that, for example, they
don't care about uh the the girls in
Afghanistan and they're not they don't
give two craps about that. They don't
care. They use it as a disguise. They do
not care. If they genuinely cared about
women's rights, they would be stopping
what's happening in Gaza. Yes, feminists
will be on the streets speaking about
what's happening in Gaza. But they
don't. It's all for their own benefits.
Brothers and sisters, there's nothing
else to be saying inshallah. Um on my
next video of Andreate, we speak about
about Illuminati. how Andrew talks about
uh the ones who are controlling the
world and who how they are trying to
manipulate us and him. Uh but we'll be
in doing reaction video to that very
soon. Inshallah you can watch that video
from sisters. That's all I have to say
in I hope Andrew take comes out and
explains to us why he used the same
strategy, the same deception, the same
manipulation as mainstream media when he
accused Muslims of take carrying out
free attacks that had nothing to do with
them. I want to know what games he's
playing. Till then brothers and sisters,
I would say be still worry about Andrew
Tate. That's all I have to say in
sisters.